ما فرص صدور اجراءات مؤقته
لوقف الاعمال العدائيه او القتال لحين
الوصول الى مرحله الحكم في هذه القضيه هل
هل هل هنالك اي حجج يمكن ان تسوقها
اسرائيل يوم غد تمنع صدور اجراءات
مؤقته في الجزء الاول من سؤالك الجواب انه
ثمت
معيار يتعلق بانه اذا كانت المحكمه تعتبر
ان هنالك احتمال جدي بوقوع جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه تامر
ب اجراءات حمائه يعني مثل مثلا وقف النار
اطلاق النار او العمليات
العسكريه او حمايه المدنيين في هذا الوقت
لماذا تامر بذلك لان المساله لا تحتمل
الانتظار حتى صدور قرار نهائي في اساس
القضيه وهذا سيستغرق شهورا عديده ان لم
يكن بضعه سنوات صحيح فبالتالي ان هذا
القرار التمهيدي الاجرائي البدائي الاولي
سيكون متخذا مفترض في خلال ايام الى
اسبووعين تقريبا من الان مفترض وهل هو
ملزم يعني اذا صدر هل هو ملزم نحن نعلم ان
اسرائيل موقعه على اتفاقيه
منع التعذيب والمعاقب
عليه ووقعت كما اشار فريق جنوب افريقيا
اليوم وقعت بدون تحفظ شانها في ذلك شان
جنوب افريقيا فبالتالي اي قرار من المحكمه
الان في هذه النقطه تحديدا هل هو ملزم
لاسرائيل
هي للتوضيح هي عضو وقد ابرمت اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه و المعاقبه عليها هذه هي
يعني عنوان الاتفاقيه لاحظ معي له مدلول
اي منع الاباده والمعاقب عليها هي اتفاقيه
عام 48 ابرمتها اسرائيل في ديسمبر عام
1950 اذا نعم هي ملتزمه بها واي خرق لهذه
الاتفاقيه يجعل ان الامم المتحده ممثله
باعلى جهاز قضائي هي محكمه العدل الدوليه
صالحه للنظر بذلك انما جوابا على الجزئيه
الثانيه من سؤالك المشكله
الاشكاليه القانونيه تكمن في مدى توافر
شروط الاباده الجماعيه ستحاق اسرائيل
اعتقد ابتداء من يوم غد بتوافر هذه
العناصر
ربما ستكون هنالك بالنسبه لبعض القضاه من
القضاه ال 15 الذين يؤلفون هيئه المحكمه
بالنسبه لبعضهم ربما تكون الاوصاف مختلفه
يعني التوصيف الجرمي ربما يكون جريمه حرب
او جريمه ضد الانسانيه لكن ليس بالضروره
جريمه اباده جماع
وهذا عائق من العوائق التي ستضعها اسرائيل
امام المحكمه اضافه الى تزرعها بحق الدفاع
المشروع عن النفس وهو حق مقدس لكنه ليس
مطلقا يعني
لا ق المدنيين بحجه محاربه مسلحين لو
المحامي في جنوب افريقيا المحامي
البريطاني والبروفيسور في اكسر قال انه لا
ينطبق على اسرائيل لانها سلطه احتلال وفق
قرار المحكمه محكمه العدل الدوليه
2014 صحيح فضلا عن مبدا التناسب يعني حتى
لو مثلا ارادت الدفاع عن نفسها فيجب ان
تحترم معايير معينه وقواعد خلال الحروب
مثل التناسبيه يعني مبدا النار لا يمكن ان
يكون مفتوحا على نحو مطلق وكثيف وغير
متناسب مع الفعل الاساسي اذا كان مشكو
منها هذا الفعل الاساسي بحيث لا يرقى ايضا
للاباده الجماعيه لانه لا يوجد ما يبر
الاباده الجماعيه على اي الاحوال نشكرك
شكرا
جزيلا الدكتور بول مرقص استاذ
القانون
والمحامي ورئيس جمعيه جوستيسيا من بيروت